that can be considered. The CHSH game is an
example of a class of games called non-local games.
Here's the setup in general
for a non-local game.
We have two players, Alice and Bob, who cooperate as a team, so they either win together
or they lose together.
This means that they have no
incentive to act selfishly, so it's essentially the opposite
extreme to zero sum games,
which are purely competitive, here the game is purely cooperative.
There's a third entity called the referee.
The referee isn't a player in the game, but rather the referee
runs the game, and in fact, you can think about the specification
of a particular instance
of a non-local game and the specification of a
referee as being equivalent.
There's a critically important constraint that's placed on Alice and Bob, which is that once the game starts, they're forbidden from
communicating with one another.
They can agree beforehand on
whatever strategy they choose, but no communication
is allowed between them during the game itself.
If you like, you can imagine
the game taking place in a secure facility of some sort as if the referee is playing
the role of a detective
and Alice and Bob are suspects located in different
rooms in a police station, but another way of
thinking about the setup
is that Alice and Bob are
separated by a vast distance and communication is prohibited because the speed of light
doesn't allow for communication
to happen quickly enough. If Alice tries to send a
message to Bob for instance, the game will be over by
the time Bob receives it.
The way a non-local game
works is that first, the referee asks both
Alice and Bob a question.
Alice's question is labeled X and Bob's question is labeled Y.
In general, you can think about X and Y as being classical states
from whatever classical states that you like and in the
specific case of the CHSH game,
X and Y are bits.
Alice and Bob must then provide answers, Alice's answer is labeled A,
and Bob's answer is labeled B,
and again, these answers can be viewed as classical states in general and like the questions, they
will be bits in the CHSH game.
At this point, the
referee makes a decision, Alice and Bob either win or they lose depending on whether or not
the pair of answers A, B
is deemed correct for the
pair of questions X, Y that the referee asked, and I'll say a little bit more
about this in just a moment.
First, let's take a
closer look at the referee to understand what it is
that's potentially challenging for Alice and Bob in a non-local game.
And what makes a non-local
game potentially challenging is that the referee can use randomness to choose the questions X and Y.
That means that Alice
and Bob have uncertainty, they don't know ahead of time what question they're going to be asked, and perhaps more importantly,
they don't know what question
the other one received and it's that uncertainty
together with the fact that they can't communicate
that presents the challenge.
So, it's similar to the situation where a detective
interrogates two suspects in different rooms, if
the suspects don't know
what questions the other one is asked, it's much harder if they're guilty to keep their story straight.
Now, I mentioned a short
time ago that the referee makes a determination
that Alice and and Bob have either answered
correctly or incorrectly
depending upon the questions
that they were asked.
It's assumed that this
determination is made according to some fixed
rule and you can consider any rule that you want,
but whatever it is,
it is assumed that Alice
and Bob know the rule, so at least they have a fighting
chance to answer correctly.
We'll take a look at the
rule for the CHSH game in a moment, but we could
consider a different rule and we would have a different
example of a non-local game.
Some non-local games are interesting and in fact some are quite fascinating in mysterious to this day and
some aren't so interesting,
that's just the nature of
the non-local game model.
Anyway, these are the two different things that are needed to describe a referee; how exactly are the questions chosen
and which answer pairs are correct for each possible question pair.
If we have a description
of those two things, then we have a description for the referee and that effectively describes
an instance of a non-local game.
Now let's take a look at
the CHSH game specifically.
The way that the game is
defined or, equivalently, how the referee is defined is as follows;
first, as I've already mentioned, the questions and answers are all bits, so the referee sends a bit X
to Alice and a bit Y to Bob,
and they each respond with a bit. Alice responds with A
and Bob responds with B.
The way the referee chooses
which questions to ask is simple, he chooses
them uniformly at random,
so, the pair of questions X, Y is equally likely to be anyone
of the four possibilities, zero, zero, zero, one,
one, zero, and one, one.
Finally, the rule that
determines which answers win and which answers lose is
that a pair of answers A, B is correct for the pair of questions X, Y